y han recuperado fuerza convertido
nuevamente en huracán ahora tienen la
mira las carolinas y al estado de
Georgia Mientras tanto Florida cuenta
sus heridas y se prepara para un conteo
doloroso
este podría ser el huracán más mortífero
en la historia de la Florida los números
aún no están claros pero estamos
escuchando los primeros informes de lo
que puede haber una pérdida sustancial
de vida la presencia del líder de la
Casa Blanca en la sede de la agencia
Federal para el manejo de emergencia
fima es el prólogo de una recuperación
que se anuncia larga y difícil
Mientras tanto en la Península de la
Florida el panorama es desolador tras
las marejadas ciclónicas y los vientos
sostenidos de más de 240 kilómetros por
hora los condados de Sarasota y
Charlotte uno de los más afectados
reportan sus primeros fallecidos con
cifras a un confusas y con tendencia al
alza el gobernador local ron de santis
informó sobre las labores de rescate que
se están llevando a cabo Incluso se negó
a dar una cifra probable de fallecidos
han habido reportes de cientos de
muertes en el condado de Lee tiene algo
que decir nada
de eso está confirmado creo que eso es
que hubo llamadas al 911 en el que las
personas dijeron Oye el agua está
subiendo a mi casa voy a subir al ático
pero estoy muy preocupado por supuesto
ahora se verificarán a esas personas
para tener Claridad al próximo día y que
los socorristas puedan ir a esos lugares
y determinar si las personas necesitan
servicios o pueden ser rescatados
hasta el momento las compañías locales
de Electricidad informaron que más de
2,6 millones de hogares y negocios en
Florida no contaban con servicio
eléctrico en las áreas tradicionalmente
turísticas ahora convertidas en zona de
desastre continúan las labores de
búsqueda y rescate con la ayuda de
embarcaciones y helicópteros